[Music]
give it up oh no just kind of stabbed me
in the gut you guys got bubba a
traumatic experience to say the least
oh i like to flip my knife
flip it in the air
this is a bit of a turn
i
don't know you even wrote a song oh god
that's because i understand where i'm
gonna stab my knife what am i doing with
my life i play five finger fillet
blinded from the light of day every hit
is just a guess this could be a bloody
mess faster faster here we go what am i
doing
don't take your eyes off my god i don't
want to see him stab himself like [ __ ]
so he flipped it four times and then he
did five finger fillet how how many
times do you think you can accurately
flip a knife and consistently catch it
probably do four we are here at alex
barbatus's car
i'm the beard judge and we're gonna see
how many times we can flip a knife i
think if we didn't use real knives
we could probably do way more than i
mean catch it like this it's totally
okay if you catch it like this it's
slowly okay if you catch it like this
it's a cut a real knife you'll cut
yourself okay we don't want to cut
ourselves because we have work to do
that involves our soft little pressure
what happens if you catch it by the
blade
come get your blood all right let's see
all right i'm going first every time you
touch the blade you lose a finger for
the rest of the day okay okay okay let's
all agree to this okay all right
it's agreed
come on red
we gotta do a group
and i flipped my knife once and i
flipped my knife twice
oh no
oh
ready
i forgot about the fact that if it hits
my hand i lose a finger i wasn't
thinking gosh dang it okay
all right first try all right go all
right one flip i'm not singing
one okay two flips
butterfingers
three flips
[Music]
if you aren't confident you're gonna
catch it don't try to i'm gonna look at
the blade on this one
oh
[Music]
why is this happening so soon
hello
hey everybody
it's been a while it's been a month
has it it's been around if you'll
remember i had to have this spider-man
short that i'm working on done by the
end of june and it is currently
july 13th it's going to be a 10-minute
short film and i am nowhere near
completion we're we're working at it
every day working hard coming in late
leaving early
who's we oh my multiple personalities
i'm working on my very own spider-man
short film you may be asking why
spider-man i can even make my own
superhero and i wouldn't have to worry
about copyright bs or anything like that
but
spider-man holds a special deer place in
my heart i've been a big fan of
spider-man my whole life grew up
watching the samurai spider-man movies
as i talked about before i thought gosh
darn it i'm gonna do it and so i made a
little teaser video i was planning on
doing a kickstarter then i got a lot of
warnings about cease and desist called
jacob talked about it he was like might
not want to do that also send us over
what you have and we'll take a look at
it so i sent them the preview they dug
it they saw the visual effects i was
doing and so they believed that i could
make a whole short film out of it and so
they were like here's a budget a go make
your own spider-man short film we're not
going to help you out they lent me gear
of course i thought they might have
notes on the script but no they were
just like shoot it do whatever you want
it was really great they gave me a lot
of creative control which is a good
thing and a bad thing because if i screw
this all up it's all on me that's a
little scary to be honest this is the
first really big project
that is all under my control the impulse
is to do absolutely everything to write
it which i did to direct it which i did
to shoot it which i did but one of the
things i learned while making this film
is really the importance of delegating
and trusting people to do their job well
and step back and focus on your own job
yeah it was really difficult shooting at
myself which was a big mistake i should
have you know i have many friends who
are very talented with uh shooting and
it would have been a much better idea to
bring one of them on being behind the
camera worrying about the framing and
following the actors and focus pulling
and all that really just takes away from
my job as a director this
is my own custom-made spider-man suit i
didn't sew it i made the design in
photoshop i sent that to this company
zentai zone it's a website where you
send them your patterns and they'll
print it onto spandex sew it together
and send it back to you and they also do
some really cool things like
adding rubber soles they add u-zippers
in the back and no line down the back of
the suit which is great eye holes which
is really nice
man the next part pains me to even talk
about a traumatic experience to say the
least i
so we're thinking too hard about
how many times we're flipping it i think
we should let the camera determine that
and we should just flip
and do it natty yeah all right ready yep
[Music]
no
oh you lost your thumb gosh i'm gonna
switch to my left soon
[Laughter]
my thumb is just now attached i have no
opposable card
whoa
[Music]
oh i actually didn't get any blood on me
okay he didn't get blood on
you it stabbed you right
right
it went straight through your whole hand
it was like
man this is gonna hurt to take off
we thought we were gonna be so good
i'm gonna attempt
don't don't worry about seven
[Music]
that was just pure luck that was pierced
ten i wanna do ten i'm gonna do ten
right now oh god
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna go switch to my left dude
like you guys still gotta what's the
lucky guy over here what a ridiculous
thing to put on my hand i'm switching to
left because i have no opposable thumb
on my right i'm going to try to beat
ren's
seven
you're dead
you actually died it just kind of
stabbed me in the gut earlier that's
from just now what happened to your lab
coat
yeah what
how many was that
a lot just go anywhere
no is it dry
you gotta do that again
i hit the handle you've gone four times
nico you've done four times you would
never catch that throwing knives at cars
go red go okay i'm gonna go for ten
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was really good right
you have an impressive rotation speed
i'm one of the nice guys dude seems like
he's such a knife guy
the nicest guy the knife is the nicest
dude who is the nicest dude three four
five five six seven eight nine ten
wow that's
that's totally skill
the next part pains me to even talk
about it was a traumatic experience to
say the least i puffy painted
this entire suit actually not the entire
suit i couldn't even finish it and it
took
probably like 40 to 50 hours and i
didn't even do it as well as some people
do it online there are cosplayers
puffy paint i had to figure out a face
shell because if you'll notice in the
spider-man movies you never really see
the outline of his nose or his jaw when
he's speaking except for spider-man
homecoming because it's cgi
[Music]
so the next part is very important for
the look of spider-man face shell the
face shell basically you put it on the
actor and then the actor puts the suit
over the shell so that there aren't any
distortions the nose isn't poking
through making it look awkward or
anything like that i ordered this
online from a guy named derek hackl very
talented man his instagram is heroes
anthony definitely if you're looking to
buy spiderman face shell check it out i
picked this one because it had a very
similar feel to the classic spider-man
look in the comics it has magnetic eyes
that fit in did he make those too he
made all this man he 3d printed he
vacuum sealed back you formed back you
formed
man that's super sweet reason for the
magnetic eyes is so
you can put the face shell under the
suit
like so you just plop these babies in
there and they stay on there's no actor
in here right now so it's real wrinkly
but you get the idea
pretty cool right so the next step in
creating the suit was to make a chest
emblem in a back end so the original
plan was to 3d print molds for each
piece and then fill those molds with
silicone paint the silicone glue it on
unfortunately
i am not experienced enough with
silicones to figure this [ __ ] out what
happened with the chest spider 3d print
wasn't high resolution enough it looked
blocky and bad with the back spider i
actually got a pretty good looking back
spider but unfortunately i couldn't get
the silicone to stick onto the suit hot
glue didn't work it just wouldn't stick
it was too slick i even tried to sand it
didn't work very well couldn't get it to
work we tried to fix this by spray
gluing it on on set every five minutes
which worked for a little bit you can
see it in a few scenes
but it left an awful residue that now
i'm going to have to paint out in every
single shot of spider-man's back this
leads us to the other insane amount of
work which is all the cgi i'll be doing
have you ever heard the phrase we'll fix
it in post
damn it i'm gonna do it and i'm gonna do
so much cgi my ass is gonna burn off
from sitting in this seat i'm gonna get
hemorrhoids from so much sitting it's
gonna be great
unless i can get a standing desk which
do we have one more
do you not have a spreadsheet oh you're
not cataloging your shots i was making a
spreadsheet but then the spreadsheet was
taking more work than the vfx so i
stopped dude
mom i'll make my bed later
but look at this organized spreadsheet
for shooting
that's right
i mean i it but
you see the the thing because it's used
dirt on it's like on on set type shot
list so it doesn't
directly help in post how many effect
shots do you have so there's um is it
more than 50 yeah is it less than 100 i
don't know it's gonna be 10 minute video
you want to get this done by the end of
this month
yeah you have two weeks
a big challenge when making any movie
where a character is wearing a mask is
going to be the sound because that sound
coming out of their mask getting picked
up
from that bless you any dialogue coming
out of that mask is going to be garbage
and so what we've had to do for this
short film and what most filmmakers do
for characters that wear masks is we
basically just re-recorded the entire
film in adr things one of the parts of
this project that i'm most excited about
is the score not the soundtrack not the
list of songs that we picked out to fit
the movie the score the orchestral score
that is being done by the insanely
talented casey edwards who has worked on
a bunch of projects with corridor rocket
jump bunch of video games super talented
guy sound design is going to be a big
part of this project so worst case
scenario i'll do it myself i can manage
making sound but what would really push
it over the top is getting someone very
talented to do it there's someone i have
in mind maybe
another person maybe would be c mike if
he's down i i hope it's not me because
anyone else would do a much better job
and it's a very important part of the
film that i hope is done well whether i
can finish it by the end of july
i guess we'll find out this is my final
attempt i'm going for 11.
ah
no tip i've been a doctor for 30 years
where
dude right here dude i love you i gotta
lose that dude
i'm all chopped up
i promise you 11. i'm gonna exceed my
promises you guys gotta get good at
throwing it above yourself and not like
yeah you got my thumb is cut off so
i see you using your thumb right now
that's not even close to 10. give it up
don't do it
dreams i dude alone
narrow streets of cobblestone
[Music]
that's a whole old scale oh
[Applause]
oh no
okay what do i have to do now 11. you
got to do 11. i got to 11. 11. jake
we're gonna be all out of tape dude keep
your ad blocker off so we can afford
more tape for rings
[Music]
little x's over his
eyes oh man
everyone is going for 11. speeding ready
boys yep
three two one
[Music]
got i got it i got it how many did you
get
you know 11 11
11.
what did we learn i learned that you
should never do this with a real knife
hey don't do this at all looking forward
to the montage of us working for the
rest of the day with all of our limbs
missing
we should probably go back we're
actually doing that
all right well time for me to go do
actual work now i'll see you guys later
the dog you're thinking of was his
girlfriend's dog
hey i can actually do work
there we
it's really warm in this jacket but it's
taped to me so i can't take it off
at the end of july i will be leaving la
to go back to san francisco to go to
school if that happens i will no longer
be able to use these fancy computers i
will be using this thing doing all the
visual effects on this thing will be
nearly impossible that gives me two
weeks to do all these visual effects to
get all of the pieces together into a
cohesive
movie